Las Vegas potentially feeling luckier
than usual today long-held St Patrick's
Day Celebrations happening all across
the valley and in true Irish tradition
those parties don't end tonight Ryan
Matthey joins us live from one of them
outside New York New York hey Ryan
Kirsten hey I'm feeling very lucky today
I got my sand rocks to prove it but at
math with everybody else here today
these people have been going at it in
New York New York since 10 this morning
other celebrations in the valley began
yesterday several others last through
the weekend and some looking to do more
good than just a good time
the top of the morning when the alien
pipes first sounded at New York New York
casino I come here every year Joe
artelejo has made the Trek from Utah to
this celebration since 2009 kilt on
point this is a good place to make new
friends that you're gonna have friends
for forever good luck follow you morning
and night cheers this celebration alone
expected to bring over 3 000 people
today it's ten dollars is the entry fee
and of course the beer is on you right
according to food and beverage director
Ryan hink 19 years ago it was just the
patio that's behind me and that was
really it now it's just grown because
people want more of it
just off the strip mcmullen's Irish Pub
cooking up 200 pounds of corned beef
expecting to sell 400 plates
further up the boulevard the Fremont
experience starting their Shamrock bash
Thursday
with 144 hours of free live
entertainment through Monday we've been
here 17 years now and just outside the
experience hog and Heifers with
professional firefighters of Nevada
using the day to fundraise for fallen
firefighters it goes back to the east
coast Boston New York where a lot of the
firefighters were from Irish ascent and
it just became a celebration and kind of
tied into the firefighter traditions
hopefully several ride apps or Rideshare
apps rather are offering discounts for
people to make sure you get home for now
I'm gonna go find some green beer
reporting live at New York New York
casino Brian Matthew 8 News Now
I join the crowd thanks Ryan